welcome to the macmillan report i'm
marilyn wilkes your host and our guest
is eli yahoo stern
assistant professor of modern jewish
intellectual and cultural history judaic
studies religious studies and history
his first book the genius
elijah of vilna and the making of modern
judaism has just been released by yale
university press
he researches the transformation and
development of traditional and religious
world views in western life and thought
today we talk with him about his next
project dealing with the relationship
between religion and secularism in the
rise of zionism welcome professor stern
pleasure to be here
you are working on a new um book project
on the
origins of zionism let's talk a little
bit about this and can you define
zionism for us well zionism was a
national movement a jewish national
movement that emerged in the second half
of the 19th century
in eastern europe and it focused on
a
jewish renewal and the attempt to bring
about a transformation of jewish society
from being a religion into a nation
that would be able to ultimately
gain a homeland and have political
sovereignty
so that's what zionism generally was
about
my book project
what i tried to focus on
is
the origins and the history surrounding
the origins of modern zionism when most
people think about zionism they think
largely about theodore herzl
uh the the viennese austrian journalist
who famously supported and promoted in
western european countries the idea of
jews returning
to a homeland
and protecting themselves against
anti-semitism for example
just a few years ago when president
obama was in cairo egypt he described
the jewish homeland as being a function
and a response to anti-semitism
in modern life and that the jewish
homeland was largely created in order to
protect jews against the atrocities the
pogroms and of course uh the holocaust
that happened in the 20th century
when most people think about zionism
they attach it to the issue of
anti-semitism
so most histories begin either with
their theodore herzl
and his experience witnessing the
dreyfus affair when alfred dreyfus the
uh the r the french army men was accused
of treason
and eventually
was um
eventually was cleared of that charge
and the charge was brought because of
him being a jew
other people will begin modern zionism
in 1880 in eastern europe with pogroms
that happened in ukraine that led to a
whole group a mass migration of jews
leaving eastern europe
off to palestine and beginning to
resettle the land in palestine where
jewish life would begin to re re-emerge
in the 19th and 20th century
what i try to do in in this next book
that i'm working on
is ask the question well why why did
they immediately go to palestine what
was
behind them thinking at this point
why did this program lead them
to say i'm going to pick up i'm going to
go all the way off to the middle east
and i'm going to resettle a land which
is largely swampland with nothing on it
i'm gonna go through that hardship
and
um and and leave my family and what i
discovered was there's actually a second
story okay behind uh the origins of
modern zionism not one that just deals
with the issue of anti-semitism but an
internal story in terms of the crises
and challenges of jewish life okay and
what what attracted you to this story
what led you to to begin writing this
book well
the story really largely revolves around
the way in which in 1795
the russian empire took over eastern
european lands from the polish
lithuanian commonwealth taking over
over the lives of over one million jews
and what it asked those jews to do was
transform themselves from being part of
a corporate entity
from being part of a corporation
largely living as a state within a state
and transforming themselves into a
religion so jews were no longer going to
be responsible for their socioeconomic
well-being
rather
all they were was a religious group and
as a religious group they were entitled
to being able to express themselves only
and strictly in religious terms so they
weren't a different nation
they were simply a different religion
now the russian government took them
through fits and bouts
of them allowing jews to actually
become
a religion because they constantly were
going back and forth in terms of
granting them their own autonomous space
and at the same time demanding that they
reform themselves to
become subjects of a state and
simply religious uh practitioners and
what i realized was was jewish life went
from largely being a cohesive whole
which had very little ideological breaks
or fractures which was largely based on
geography and local custom to all of a
sudden in 19th century the birth of
radically new and different religious
ideologies
so there emerged in the 19th century
khasidism which was a pietistic
spiritual movement there were
enlighteners who were reform-minded
jews who believed in secular studies and
a transformation of jews
professionalized and there were people
who embraced the modern yeshiva which
was a religious learning institution
this fractured jewish life
so you went from largely cohesive body
politic in the 18th century which was
governed through a corporate structure
to all of a sudden all these various
different denominations and ideologies
what zionism
came to do when it emerged in the 1870s
and 1880s
through people like
forerunners like moses lillian bloom and
perez molenskin was it wanted to address
the fractures in jewish life it wanted
to be able to do two things
number one
reunify the jewish people
bring them back together as a cohesive
whole which had largely been
undone by the last 60 years of them
becoming or expressing themselves in
various religious ways that seems like a
very uh big
hope though right now the way they were
going to accomplish that hope you're
right it's a it's a really big hope
because you know that you know the
famous joke you have two jews in the
room what do you get three opinions
so
it actually was a a very difficult task
and what they did
was they said okay
we know that they're all these various
disputes some people see judaism as
being about texts and study some people
see it about
rituals
some see it being about reform and
reason
what we're going to do is we're going to
say the religious aspects of judaism are
not the primary identity of the jewish
people
jews are first and foremost they would
argue a nation
and rather than seeing them in religious
terms the real revolution that zionism
is going to inaugurate that's going to
lay the groundwork for herzl's
eventual
emergence in eastern europe
is going to be a transformation from
religious to a secular understanding of
judaism that judaism was not simply
a religion but rather it was a nation
and it could be understood in purely
secular terms now what the secular terms
did was it allowed both religious
and reform conservative and orthodox to
be able to come under a larger national
project that bracketed all the
divisiveness and debate
over do i believe in god or do i not
believe in god and address people's
socio-economic well-being but why was
that important
well it was important because
as one as one critic put it the crisis
of the fork and the knife
which was
the russian state was unable
in eastern europe to provide jews with
the kind of socio-economic opportunities
to better their lives
so while they force jews to become
privatized stripping of them
of their
political autonomy they were unable to
provide them with opportunities that
would allow them to put bread on the
table so what zionism said was we want
to address the fact that you are going
hungry
we're going to have to figure out a way
to be able to to to better your uh to be
able to better your socioeconomic
situation and the only way to do that is
to get out of these religious debates
and to be able to focus on improving and
bettering the
the national aspects of jewish life
okay um so basically
what does zionism tell us more generally
about the nature of secularism and
nationalism well
there's been a long time myth
um in in the zionist narrative that
zionism was simply something secular
that came out of a table rasa that
emerged with no uh with no forerunners
before it herzl for example couldn't
speak hebrew
that myth has largely been discredited
if you look at the history of zionism
you see that there are
many examples of religious language
religious ideals and ideas that permeate
zion early zionist rhetoric so for
example
perez molenskin one of the
proto-zionists in the late 19th century
argues for
argues for jewish nationalism based on
the idea of tikvah tikva is the hebrew
word for hope and what what smolinska
did was he took a messianic biblical
concept and he turned it into what we
would call today the politics of hope
and redemption
which clearly has religious connotations
but ends up
moving into a space that can be
understood free of any metaphysical
assumptions
and that's rationalized and universally
accessible so what i'm trying to show in
my research is
the connection
between secularism
and religion but at the same time the
transformation that occurs so for
example while
america certainly draws from biblical
motifs and ideals
it attempts though to take those ideals
and motifs and turn them into a
universal language that's accessible to
all peoples so too when you look at the
zionist project it's taking ideas that
certainly come from what we would call
jewish literature but what it's doing is
it's further rationalizing that
literature
freeing it of its metaphysical
assumptions and opening it up to a wider
public
so for example when moses lillian bloom
will talk about forerunners to zionism
he'll actually point to a man named
joseph salvador a christian born
french not early 19th century thinker
who called for a reproachment between
jews and christians and the return of
that new group to the holy land salvador
was not a rabbinically jewish man
he was actually born of a christian
mother and yet for lillian bloom who was
one of the precursors and forerunners of
modern zionism
salvador was his inspiration
okay so how
will your book
differ from the body of work that is is
available today
well what i'm hoping to do is i'm hoping
to be able to intervene i think in a
really important debate
that's going on right now in academic
and in political circles which is
a number of people have recently begun
to explore the religious roots of
zionism and question whether or not the
movement because of those roots
is able to ultimately will ultimately be
able to achieve a democratic liberal
state
being israel
and what they point to it's both on the
one hand
many of zionism's critics and some of
its staunchest defenders is that zionism
ultimately is based on a certain
biblical
messianic worldview
with all kinds of apocalyptic dangerous
apocalyptic
uh possibilities
its staunch supporters will say yes the
bible shows
that the this is the jewish homeland
its defenders will say the fact that
it's
it's it's uh critics zionism critics
will say the fact that zionism is
attached to biblical messianic concepts
shows that ultimately it will never be
able to free itself of certain racist
and exclusivist tendencies
so both on the left and the right
the attempt to see zionism in religious
terms
complicates and in some ways undermines
the ability for israel to remain a
secular democratic state what i'm what
my work is trying to do is trying to
shed light on the relationship between
religion
and secularism to show while in its
roots it pulls from
certain religious texts such as the
bible nonetheless zionism transforms
those texts works through them in order
to make the state of israel something
that is
more accessible more rational freed of
its metaphysical assumptions ultimately
liberal and democratic
and that tension it's really that
tension between secularism and and and
religion that all of us in western life
are constantly uh constantly working
through america
europe has a whole christian history as
well
which it pulls from in terms of its
values and ideals and yet is constantly
trying to work through
that history
in order to not let it
not let their political institutions
remain closed but rather open them up
and make them accessible to people of
various faiths with various racial and
ethnic backgrounds and that's really one
of the great challenges of western life
which is largely our secular
institutions have come out
of a religious world view
and how do we at on one hand
respect where those values come from but
recognize that we want to make
these institutions open and accessible
to people from various backgrounds
so what do you think the future holds
for zionism
i think that's uh if i i am no prophet
and i think that actually one of the
most important things that i'm arguing
is precisely we don't know and that's
what we have to live with
if you see zionism in simply messianic
religious terms you know what the future
holds
it holds apocalypse it holds messiah it
holds god coming down from heaven who
knows there's all kinds of
people who who have a messianic
religious
religious version of of zionism they
know what the future holds what i'm
trying to argue
is that
what it means to engage in modern
politics is not to know what the future
holds
it's to be able to live in the present
and to be able to entertain the
possibility that the future can be
anything okay
so when will your book be out
when will my book be out well my first
book just came out on elijah of vilna uh
about a month ago so i'm i'm still
working working through
the different responses i'm getting to
that this book i hope will be out in the
next year or two i'm right now finishing
finishing it up
and uh hopefully i'll have it at a
publisher sometime soon okay great we
will look forward to seeing that thank
you so much for being here with us today
thank you marilyn
for more information about professor
stern and his research please visit our
website at yale.edu
macmillan report be sure to join us
again for another episode of the
macmillan report made possible through
funding from the whitney and betty
mcmillan center for international and
area studies at yale
you